i never got that whole experience where
women have to stay home and cook and do
whatever i never
like how women talk about that i had a
mom that like busted her ass
and like worked every any job she had to
to put food on the plate like she was a
single mom for a little bit and then um
and then remarried and then saw her in
that relationship was
which was a difficult one so um you know
i
i don't know i'm really i think my mom i
don't know about you but i feel like
my my setup kind of prepared me for this
industry
i swear to you identical my mom was take
away the marriage
my mom my dad never married they were
together then they just stopped at like
a crazy young age and maybe tampered
with the possibility of getting back
together
it never happened my mom kind of shut
him out but my mom was always
you know a job plus another job
plus school trying to further her mind
and education my mom too
she put herself through college bop bop
bop
and that's not intentional yeah that was
a good plugin because she was always
back to back to back to back to back so
i do know for a fact
that's why i got my hustle and life i
think so too i think and it's actually
an
interesting question that i ask people
in the industry a lot and like just
friends like if i'm out with i'm
i don't know because every person i know
that's really successful
in the industry not i mean everyone that
i personally know not that this is
everyone's story but
i think you've had to experience some
kind of grief or
loss or struggle or to to be able to
emerge whatever to be funny on stage to
be able to really tap into that because
i think behind comedy i don't even know
if you know this but i was
a cocked waitress at a comedy club that
was one of my first jobs but i
i learned though it was interesting to
see that a lot of comedians
very funny charismatic bubbly on stage
then the club shuts down and we're all
counting money we're doing stuff
and not all of them but a lot can go
dark and i don't think that they're
necessarily
going super dark i think they go quiet
because they've had to
you have to give so much energy well you
cut it on you gotta switch but it's like
performers it's the same thing
it mirrors more than you even know
because yeah you know
there's it's like it's like the story of
the dressing room
right yeah the reason why that dressing
room exists
is because before a performance the
performer has to
have a place where they can go to
prepare
to cut that thing on and some people
really got to go through a dramatic
shift in personality and mood and
whatever
to go okay now i'm ready some people
don't some people can go some people can
entertain
be loose and then still go and do what
they do but there
is a switch in all of us
from the person that we are in
show and the person that we are out of
show
yeah and and it's learning the balance i
think you know for a lot of us
it's about understanding how to navigate
correctly
with that balance and i don't know about
you but balance is hard it was a
discovery
how did you deal with that oh i had
bought them
and it was from after performance at
irvine i hit like a real low
and it was because i didn't know that
balance i didn't know that that room was
for me
you know to have my own little space i
always let everybody and i'm very
inclusive i'm
um not great at boundaries everybody's
pulling
every yeah yeah so and i and i just
didn't know that i could say no
i didn't know i didn't want to be
difficult i didn't want to be especially
as a woman
like you know so i didn't want to be
perceived as [ __ ] or difficult what
age were you at
around this time is this fairly early in
success training
this is like heyday yeah and i think
that is
god it's such a walking cliche it's
it is always in our heyday it's like
it's always it's always that story of
everybody thinks it's hitting and it's
going so well and
and it's you know knowing how to handle
that and especially at 19 like
being the boss of grown men and women
around you is like and having to make
those decisions and
especially being raised that like you
respect your elders never
say anything other than that like and
and you can't like tell them what to do
definitely so it was a hard thing to
navigate yours was like
you were truly thrown in it like yeah
because what started off as an audition
as a shot in a million which we thought
was a joke
like you know you mean it what do you
mean would you we all thought it was
kind of a joke i mean we didn't think it
was going to come of anything like we
were the first season
of american idol so we we were there for
that paycheck that
after sag gives you to like pay for some
bills like you know nobody knew that it
would actually
come to anything would come to fruition
you know that's what
everyone hopes but that doesn't usually
happen you know so
um i don't know it we we
got thrown into it i will say i am
thankful for that at the same time
because i think i've skipped the surreal
part like of like it really doesn't
matter to me in the best sense like it
matters but like
it it matters for what the worth i give
it like it like i love what i do and i
love singing and i love
um you know what you're able to do with
your spotlight but
i think because i skipped all that so
fast and i was thrown in
there was no time for
people to really drill me on you have to
do this you have to be this
[Music]
you